and more importantly happy holidays this
is our December meet up so I probably
won't see a lot of you until the new
year I'd like to acknowledge some of our
sponsors thank you to numb focus for
sponsoring this meetup group thank you
to TD Ameritrade my employer for
providing this venue as well as thinking
of my just for providing the food that
you're enjoying a couple of points
especially for our folks who are new
here emergency exits there's one right
here to my right and also through the
doors that we're up there you just turn
right take the stairs don't get the
elevator in emergencies I always be
giving us feedback yeah there is been or
been silent on myself feel free to
either email us message us on the meetup
group or just come talk to us afterwards
we love any feedback both positive and
especially negative things that we can
improve upon also check out our PI data
page if you want to grab speaker decks
or get links to our YouTube videos
because all of our talks are recorded
and posted on YouTube so it's just look
for PI data and harbor on YouTube as
well unless the questions are quick I
try to keep them to live and also
remember that you are in a for both
space so do please clean up after
yourselves plates cups the garbage is
right by where the food is like to read
our PI data code of conduct so PI data
is dedicated to providing a harassment
free meeting experience for everyone
regardless of gender sexual orientation
gender identity and expression
disability physical appearance body size
racial religion we do not tolerate
harassment of meeting participants in
any form all communication should be
appropriate for professional audience
including people of any different
backgrounds sexual language and imagery
is not appropriate for any of our meet
of events be kind to others do not
install to put down other attendees
behave professionally remember that
harassment and sexist racism
exclusionary jokes are not appropriate
for pi data attendees violating these
rules may be asked to leave the meetup
at the sole discretion of the meetup
organizers but overall thank you for
making this a welcoming and friendly
environment for everybody so just a
quick icebreaker so that you can meet
somebody new hopefully turn to somebody
other towards your left or whether you
don't know isn't a pure of yours and
tell them whether you're whether or not
you like taking notes about
you know talks on computer or on paper
or notebook go ahead you have to add
that to the code of conduct no are you
hey hopefully you've met somebody that
you never met before and just a quick
plug for this monthly data science
there's something new like came out we
were going to wrap it which is basically
something that Nvidia is working on with
a couple of other companies but it's
basically an open-source libraries for
editing and ETL extract transform and
load and also machine learning on GPU so
sort of an end-to-end pipeline we're
doing data science sort of the next
generation of this you might have seen
some of this coming up so go ahead go
ahead and go and check it out at rapid a
I also like to plug our January meet up
event which is going to be a really good
one and this is with Claire Roberts
Thompson from trace which is a sports a
young company using sensors to
understand how sports work or maybe
better understanding how a soccer team
might benefit from you know on field
experiences and the topic of the talk is
a journey into object tracking in sports
and this will be on Wednesday I'm
piloting the read here because in the
new year we'll be moving on to run
things and then not only on January 9
also at the same time same location a
quick plug for TD Ameritrade we are
hiring so we're looking for our
researcher probably a few developers
engineers and data scientists so if
you're interested you can talk to me but
also look at ahlstrom over there
probably will will have a couple of
rolls open but feel free to chat with us
even after the fact you any calls for
community announcements whether you're
looking for a job posting a job or just
looking for people who have similar
interests to here Ben
oh I am looking for a data scientist but
the weekend design is for clients in
Canton you have to have Pharma
background and a whole bunch of DevOps
yeah see me apples thanks anyway any
mathematicians right you know who to see
any other announcements going once twice
alright great so today we have a great
talk
we have Haytham Maya as well as Brandon
stange
will be telling us about different
methods for a model interpretability so
thank you
all right so my name is Nathan Maya
Brannan stange and we're excited here to
be talking about methods for
interpretive love machine learning
please feel free throughout the talk to
like post up on here and I should see it
up here and if it kind of relates to
what I'm talking about we can answer the
questions as we go along so brain and I
work at Jewel so we're just gonna do a
quick spiel about jewel jewel is a
purpose company so what that means is
that the individual level we provide a
mobile app experience that helps users
live a healthier more purposeful life at
the organization level we provide
insights about the organization's
population and provide suggestions about
ways that an organization can improve
and make help and their employees reach
their full potential so in considering
topic for this talk Brandon and I were
kind of exploring some of the problems
we commonly face at Jewel and a lot of
them may be very familiar to do to you
some of those involve building user
trust alongside our like predictions and
recommendations that we give to users as
well as convincing domain experts in the
health and wellness industry that our
models are learning what we expect them
to learn and that they make sense and so
that kind of leads us to talk about
interpretability so to begin with what
do we mean by interpretability
there's obvious you probably have an
idea of what it means and there's
different ways you can measure it so in
order to have an interpretive
interpretable model to start with you
kind of need a stable model where you
can get reproducible predictions but
furthermore you will probably want to
know a little bit about what features
were most important when making a
prediction in a model you're probably
going to want to know something about
how relationships between certain
features resulted in a certain
prediction and then you
probably even want to know like how easy
is it for people to understand what a
model has learned about your data and so
kind of different levels of interpret
ability in different ways you can
measure that and so the question it begs
the question well if we care about
interpret ability why not just choose
the most interpret models out there and
just dump out the rest and so this kind
of explains the fact that there are a
lot of times you have to deal with a lot
of other considerations one being the
whole accuracy accuracy versus
interpretability trade-off where certain
more complicated models can do better
with more complex problems in terms of
accuracy but with that complexity
creates harder to interpret models and
it kind of brings the term black box
models where you pop in the data get the
results and just trust that it works
other there are also other
considerations including computational
restrictions and restrictions in terms
of the data that you have and the amount
of it you have but this kind of lends
itself to like discussing like the whole
kaggle effect that we've been seeing
where we keep increasing complexity to
squeeze out as just as much accuracy as
possible with the data without really
considering interpretability and so why
do we care about an interpret ability
and I was actually quite surprised to
see how in this katie nuggets poll that
there are quite a lot of machine
learning practitioners out there that
really do care about interpretability
even with all those cacklers out there
so one of the first reasons we care
about interpret abilities we need to
understand what a model has actually
learned from the data to address the
problem being solved and so with a lot
of generalization problems you kind of
explaining why prediction was made can
help detect problems with overfitting
and explaining if a models learning what
is expected that you're learning
in the example here on the left this
comes from a popular paper about the
line package and in here you're seeing
this is providing a interpret ability
for a classification problem where a
model is classifying an animal as either
a husky or a wolf
and what this is showing you here is
that the model is predicting a husky
because of our predicting wolves because
of the snow versus actually looking at
the animal and so things like interpret
this kind of shows you like some of the
significant benefits of having
interpretability even in complex models
is that there's lots of implications
especially in very sensitive domains
like in healthcare where spurious
correlations can exist and will not
always exist when making predictions and
can result in non truthful predictions
in cases where it can really impact
people's lives secondly models don't
really care what's in the data they
learn what they learn and so because of
that that can result in models learning
about bias learning from biases in the
data and so we have lots of examples
here we're in the news where models
exhibit gender and racial biases and
other kinds of biases and on the example
on the left here we actually see in a
example of like pre train were directors
trained off of the Google News data set
exhibiting clear gender biases and what
you see here is a paper that was trying
to D by us these word vectors and
showing you here on the x-axis g2 hee
and on the y-axis not gender neutral -
gender neutral terms and you can clearly
see on the top right what's supposed to
be gender neutral terms correlate more
for words like brilliant genius buddy
cocky on the he side and then things
like dress and earrings and
pageants and sewing on the seaside and
so you can see like there's lots of
examples like this where biases can
exist in beyond that one key thing is
you kind of need to be able to audit a
model especially when it comes to
working with domain experts domain
experts the own single decision to
single prediction points domain experts
will probably want to walk through the
decision-making process of a model in
order to verify what a model is learned
and making sure that it can be verified
by their domain knowledge is it backed
by science
does it make sense and then furthermore
to check the safety amount above the
model and then identify cases where
models will fail this is critical in
things like the FDA in healthcare where
models could make medical decisions can
have implications on the life of a
patient and then another thing that we
face that jool a lot is user buy-in we
need to build user trust these are some
common pieces of feedback that we've
seen kind of summarized issues related
to users being skeptical the predictions
being made not showing enough proof of
the logic and the decision making
process and why certain predictions were
made there's a common theme and so being
able to explain what a model is doing
with the data and then furthermore being
able to explain the reasoning behind
certain predictions is critical for
building user trust and then there's
also cases where we kind of have no
choice for example in the finance
industry you might be dealing with the
Fair Credit Reporting Act where you kind
of need to explain to consumers the what
information was used to deny their
credit more in the FDA where you want to
be able to audit a model and explain the
decision process so that they can verify
patient safety and restrictions around
the use of certain products
and then pretty recently examples with
gdpr which we're still unsure about the
legal implications of interpretability
but it shows that the public is becoming
more and more concerned with what
automated decision-making processes are
doing and requesting explanations for
how their personal personal data is
being used on those processes and so
providing methods for interpretability
is kind of key here for even for the
public interest regardless if you're
legally required to so now that we've
kind of talked about why we care about
interpretability we're gonna kind of
give you a brief survey of some popular
models out there and discuss their level
of interpret ability and so to start
with we kind of talk about here what we
consider perfectly interpretable
approaches and we say perfectly because
here these are models that are
interpretive oh by their very nature in
a lot of cases though you may be
sacrificing accuracy for this interpret
ability especially with complicated
problems but in turn the models can be
better understood by people so one of
the most interpretable analyses you can
do here is with the potential for
sacrificing accuracy is rule-based
analysis these are very interprete becoz
they're easy to understand and explain
how predicting an association between
factors can be inferred by
co-occurrences in the data you can also
support conclusions here with a certain
level of certainty so you can actually
say things to users even that if a and B
occurs C occurs and we're certain about
this because because it happens about 80
percent of the time so pretty
straightforward in terms of
interpretability of this of this
approach a little more complicated but
still very interpretable our decision
trees and so here split points on
certain variables who can produce
easy-to-follow decision workflows
and it's very intuitive to explain how
certain segmented outcomes became about
along with your confidence in those
outcomes a key thing to know here about
decision trees is that interpretability
heavily relies on the size of the tree
as well as the path length of the tree
because really complicated trees will
result in a lot of cognitive load and
will be very hard to follow depending on
who the person is it's trying to
interpret the model and then you have
examples with linear regression and
logistic regression in these examples
they both kind of follow the similar
concept of modeling the correlation
between certain factors and a given
outcome and here
although the parameters that are learned
are more complicated than interpreting a
decision tree or Association rules
they're still very interpretable because
they explain what the model has learned
about the relationships between the
factors and the outcomes it also tells
you how confident they are in those
relationships through p-values so with
linear regression the point estimates
determined directly the correlation
between features with logistic
regression you've learned parameters
that can be used to calculate the
likelihood of a given outcome given a
certain feature so one considerable
limitation here is that these models in
hopes of improving accuracy you could
engineer features but those features
could that your engineering you got to
be careful and make sure that they're
interpretive and by their nature too so
with more complexity you get less
interpret ability here as well and so
I'm going to hand off the mic to Brandon
who's going to start to talk about some
of the more semi interpretable
approaches
any questions so far before Haytham goes
too far yeah yeah so we did that we
identified a few Python packages or
Python functions that implement these
methods is just kind of a nice helper
and make it a little bit more related to
PI data since we're here
and those exists kind of throughout the
whole presentation so yeah Clayton I
mean there's definitely a difference
right when you're calculating an odds
ratio you have to convert it back from
the logistic transformation and the the
equation itself is multiplicative
instead of additive but it is all it's
still fairly interpreted well I would
say yeah in the back
yeah that makes sense and the stats guy
would definitely call me on that so
thanks jack and any other questions
before I move on cool so we're going to
talk about methods that are a bit in the
middle here so not perfectly
interpretable but contain some approach
for interpreter ability as kind of a
byproduct of the model itself and this
is often expressed one way through
variable importance so if you're
familiar with random forests
this is often a byproduct of calculating
a random forest you'll end up with
something like a variable importance
plot here so this is just an example of
a ranking of all of the variables and
how important they are to any given
outcome so how I'm sure most of you are
familiar with random forests and kind of
how they work but it's a combination of
many simple decision trees and how we
arrived at this importance is whether
any particular feature is included or
excluded we can calculate the accuracy
of any particular any individual tree in
this kind of random forest and if we
average across all of those instances
where a feature exists and doesn't exist
we can kind of derive the importance of
that feature so basically if it's left
out how far does the accuracy drop
across the model it also works with
gradient boosted machines you can
actually use this method through any
algorithm as long as you kind of iterate
over the top meaning that if you drop a
variable and retrain your model you can
sort of calculate the accuracy loss for
not having access to that model
so we'll talk about neural network
approaches now and I feel like every
skipped one I did so a lot of the
approaches you'll see for interpreting
neural networks are tend to be kind of
gradient based and you'll see the word
salience II referenced and generally
kind of what we're doing here the
approach I've mainly used is you take
the partial derivative of the output
with respect to the input and you end up
with a wait for the inputs on how much
they influence the output the the
downside of that is it has to be done
kind of after the fact and it's
additional computation that you have to
do it's not built into the training of a
neural network by default generally
speaking another approach that I've seen
used is a decoder on top of the neural
network to produce images kind of like
you see below you'll see it highlights
kind of areas in the image where if
thinks the decision is being made so the
the bottom tank example here I think is
from a paper called Picasso or there
that's what the algorithm is called and
I'm sure that's in our references here
but you can see it is highlighting kind
of areas where the tank is and as we
move towards trying to say this is
definitely not an amphibian it it isn't
able to highlight any areas in that
image there are some newer approaches
grad cam is one that we came across it
seems to be well liked and what that
does for image processing is it takes
the the gradients from the last
convolutional layer in a neural network
and visualizes those weights so you end
up with kind of what you're seeing over
here on the right and the ability to
highlight the dog where the dog is being
identified versus the cat yeah
no I I don't know that's interesting I
didn't actually notice that that is sort
of a weird yeah I'm not sure I wouldn't
wouldn't expect that but I would have to
dig into the paper to see if they
comment on that at all I'm not sure
so another interpretability approach you
can use with neural networks is through
various attention methods and these have
been proven to improve accuracy quite a
bit it's an approach that's been
popularized over the last couple years
and has been kind of marked as
state-of-the-art and like various kind
of NLP approaches so it's really common
with LST M's and RN ends and general
recurrent neural networks and has also
been used in convolutional neural
networks a little bit and so this one
works through kind of a memory approach
where we store weights outside of course
or the normal path of an LS TM and by
visualizing those weights and what seems
to be important for that network we can
come up with a way to highlight in text
or images and if I remember correctly
the below example was like a question
and answer type of situation so some
question was posed like who killed who
in this play or something like that and
it ended up being like entity 63 or
killed entity 23 or something like that
so this is a pretty easy approach
because you get it basically for free
you get you're going to be improving
accuracy most likely and you can just
kind of visualize the attention matrix
if you can to do it smartly and
structure it well
another approach we came across was
pretty interesting where you can
actually apply drop out on the inference
step of a neural network and this one's
a little bit different from the others
because it's not really giving you
interpret ability per se but it's giving
you a distribution on the out on the
prediction side so you're not getting a
you know an explanation for what's
causing the prediction but you're
getting sort of the distribution and the
confidence of any particular prediction
and it returns something similar to a
Bayesian posterior and I kind of put a
little asterisk on there because I'm not
smart enough to understand the paper and
the theoretical reasons why that may be
true intuitively it seemed like you
would need to tune the size of the
dropout method to sort of control the
width of the distribution and make sure
it matches with your expectations from
the data but there was an approach to
kind of calculating the optimal drop out
for the inference step the the downsides
of this it requires many additional
computations you're going to have to run
through any observation you know a
hundred a thousand times to calculate
the distribution and I probably should
have mentioned that drop out it
basically masks some variables so it you
get that variation by basically dropping
out various data elements for any given
observation and like I said we we
haven't used this approach but we
thought it was pretty cool and if
there's some theoretical kind of
foundation for why the distribution is
you know statistically valid in some way
we thought that was pretty interesting
so that papers referenced this one I
think it's a time series example so the
axis is time and then whatever they're
trying to measure on the y-axis so you
can just see that as you move across
time there's that the prediction period
and and the confidence spreads out so I
don't remember exactly what that
specific example was for but sometimes
there
approach then this is paper Haytham
found this approach is applying a
decision tree in a neural network to
regularize it and it seemed like this
was going to be you know computationally
intense and when we're not sure about
that so and I don't know of any actual
like implementations of this if you
happen to find one we'd be kind of
curious to see a so we could give it a
try but it basically learns a decision
tree while training the neural network
and it regular regularizes the
complexity of the neural network through
the depth of the trees so as you move
from left to right here it's increasing
the regularization so on the left is a
pretty complex tree and by the rate you
basically get the most simple tree
possible which is just a single node the
examples that they give are often kind
of healthcare-related here and this
isn't something that we've we've used
but we we thought that was a pretty
interesting approach so if anyone has
done anything like that let us know it's
a pretty cool one so model agnostic
approaches so these are models where
approaches where you can apply them to
any predictive model I need machine
learning algorithm and get some
interpretability out of it excuse me so
this is one that we use pretty often at
jewel actually and it's it's super
simple and I haven't seen too many
people kind of talk about it and I don't
know if that's because it's super
obvious or people don't think about it
or or what but you can get
interpretability out of a network just
by varying the inputs and measuring the
outcome from that particular model so an
example might be like housing prices if
I want to figure out which kind of
project I should take on around the
house like revamping a kitchen or adding
a bathroom or something I can actually
adjust my observation to
you know reflect those changes run that
through the predictive model and get you
know a an expected price for a house so
we use this at Jewel pretty often just
to explain explain predictions to users
in the sense that you know if we're
predicting like how you're gonna sleep
tomorrow or today we want to give kind
of some feedback for what can you do to
kind of optimize that and depending on
the day it might be something like being
more active or eating more healthy or
something like that so we can provide
targeted feedback to users through this
pretty simple approach the downside is
it requires pretty careful planning and
understanding of the problem and the
data because you can easily apply
transformations to your data that are
sort of invalid that you don't see often
enough in the data to make sense so an
example might be like adding too many
bathrooms to a house where it doesn't
exist or something like that so other
downsides is this requires multiple
predictions on the same observation so
it can get pretty out of hand if you
want to do all combinations of all your
variables but it works really well in
kind of a targeted situation where you
want to say you know of these five or
ten inputs if you increase each of them
by 10% you know what's the expected
change in the outcome variable one of
the complicating factors is variables
tend to move together so if you're
adding an expansion on your house you're
gonna add square footage and rooms and
maybe a bathroom or something all
together so depending on the type of
predictive model you use you may want to
move variables together
and this is the the most core kind of
Python package I think this one started
as a Python package and it might be
available in our and other languages now
but its line local interpretable model
agnostic explanations and that's pretty
tortured acronym but here it is and it
works basically the same way by
perturbing the input data and measuring
the effect on the outcome of a
predictive model and generally you're
kind of zeroing out regions of an image
or an image in this case but it works
for kind of any type of data and they're
continually adding more so you can see
on the image case they do kind of create
some like super pixels in areas of the
image and then basically they blank out
areas of the image and then run that
image through the predictive model to
see kind of what has the most impact
they also fit a linear model over top of
that and then actually just interpret
that that linear model there's also a
text example down here where the words
that are most similar or most predictive
of you know any particular outcome can
be highlighted but it works with tabular
data text data image data and that are
always expanding it so if you're looking
for something easy and you want to
basically apply it to some method that's
considered black box like a neural
network this is a really good way to go
obviously the downside is anything that
you're doing on top of an additional
model like this requires kind of
additional computation so you want to
keep that in mind if you're going to be
using kind of these interpretations and
presenting them back to users and doing
that sort of thing
so takeaways yeah sure shoot yeah I'll
repeat it yeah so he was highlighting
that local is kind of the first word in
lime here and reading the paper what
they mean by local is basically that
they're taking one observation so like
one house price prediction all the
features going into a house price and
perturbing those and then they use a
wait for the similarity to the original
that they also feed into that linear
model so what you end up with is local
meaning what is the impact on this
observation on the outcome it's not
trying to learn the whole model so any
interpretation you get from that it's
really based on that observation it's
not attempting to explain the whole
model it's only useful in that case
any other questions before we kind of
summarize here I I would say I mean for
for accuracy our some neural network
approaches that kind of you do get for
free a little bit like the intention
approach and I think based on the
complexity of what you're trying to
explain there might be some benefit to
trying take advantage of that free
computation other than that we're kind
of big fans of the model agnostic
approaches because they work really
broadly but obviously if you're doing
something like like scientific research
you know that's why linear and logistic
models are so popular because they're
you know free there it's the whole point
of the model is to explain it you're not
really shooting for accuracy most of the
time so basically we're just summarizing
kind of the difficult to interpret
approaches to the perfectly
interpretable approaches and this is
everything we just kind of reviewed but
the the major takeaways are sometimes
depending on your use case
interpretability can be as important or
more important than pure accuracy which
is sort of different than a lot of the
literature you end up reading Haven
mentioned Cagle and a lot of the blog
posts seem to really focus on accuracy
and quite a bit less on interpretability
but that being said there's a pretty
good amount of research and blogs
discussing interpretability
you can always default to using more
interpretable models you know why use
something like a neural network if a
linear model works and you're focused on
interpretability so it really comes down
to kind of the use case keep your keep
the audience in mind there's a big
difference in trying to explain the
whole model at once what is the decision
framework that an entire model is making
versus what is the decision a single
observation is making and and that's a
great point for Lyme so
you but if you're trying to explain the
whole model to you know like a research
partner scientists or something like
that you're probably going to want to
use a different approach then then if
you need to explain like a single
observation to a individual user
consider your limitations and bias in
the data and several methods exist for
interpreting kind of black box models
which we just talked about line is is a
great example of that we have some good
reads here please feel free to poke
through most of these papers are kind of
referenced somewhere in the presentation
so if you saw some images that were not
attributed correctly they come from one
of these thanks to Clayton for pointing
out one of these papers what my deep
learning model doesn't know I'll
actually know is the first one the
mythos model interpretability is a great
read it's basically our presentation but
better and other than that we'll take
any questions
[Applause]
carpets were terrible
in the future I'm given that you know
with these turbo models like the basis
would you choose one of interpreting
models top subjunctive so what do you
see as will be like computer
requirements regards to interpretability
yeah the question is what do we think
the future interpret ability
requirements are for something like GD P
R and if I have answer to that I would
be really wealthy I think or something
but the way we've decided to address it
because we wanted to plan you know we in
case our users travel to Europe or if we
get a client in Europe is basically that
we're explaining what we're doing with
your data and whether a user is putting
in data in their phone and we're getting
it through like a Fitbit or something
like that we basically say here are the
broad kind of data elements that we're
using you know your location your user
enter data your kind of tracking data
and we're using it to kind of build a
prediction or make recommendations to
you so that's going to be extent at
which we're trying to comply with GDP
are right now I don't think it's been
settled in the courts yet about what
like meaningfully interpretive interpret
means
is proving to be not needed because your
interest probability
yeah and for those who can hear the
point was that with looking at model
interpret ability you may find out that
certain data elements aren't useful and
you no longer need to collect them seems
maybe that they could be insufficient to
your users I guess for instance if
you're saying oh I predict or you should
sleep more tonight right and then well
why they say well because their model
predicts do you need to sleep more
tonight right so in your experience has
that been sufficient or are you aiming
for an even higher level no we
definitely add try and give a more
interpret will answer there so we we
definitely will say something like you
know on days where it's high humidity
you tend to sleep worse what can you do
to kind of account for that and then
adjust for that so we definitely try and
meet that a slightly higher bar of
interpretability
I'm on sorry you're here don't ask it
too hard of a question
what do we mean by typical model they
all okay you know approaches they just
propose something but they what they
really do is that interpret abilities
explaining the model explaining like the
mechanical model is a linear model is a
decision trees and here on the trophy
what the model does but if we use a
knowledge of the human other highly
intelligent machines if someone asked me
why I came to this top I will say I will
say okay this is a nice and abstract
interpretable solution or statement of
you but can I can ask you to pose the
question what's the question
sorry speakers so what's a what what
what what do you see
yeah and I'm not sure we highlighted
this as well as we had planned but I
think kind of that first slide here is
is sort of posing that question like
what do we mean about interpretability
and to us I think it depends on whether
you're trying to explain the model in in
total or if you're trying to explain one
observation I think that those are two
pretty different things and I don't have
a great answer for you I I guess I would
say the the myth though of model
interpretability or whatever that paper
is called does a better job than we
would and describing kind of what is
interpreter will mean and I think that
was basically the highlight of the paper
that it that no one has a real
definition we all sort of think we
understand we understand what
interpretive will means but it really
depends on your use case I think in in
my opinion I think what you're kind of
implying here is that you were all
striving to kind of get to that like
most stringent level of defining
interpretability is the level of human
understanding for why something was made
and what you actually mean with the
prediction so yeah I don't think it's
quite well defined and if it it's kind
of one thing that you could do at a
company as a best practice is can you
define some sort of numerical score or
quantitative measure of interpretability
when defining a model is that poss
well I'm not sure but poses some
interesting questions Gordon
can you tie any of the methods for
building that you talked about back yeah
sir means that's obviously a super hard
problem because it's not as simple as
just like removing gender or removing
race out of your data right just
removing that feature doesn't
necessarily remove all of the bias that
exists for something like job titles you
have to do a lot more massaging for the
data or for the model itself to kind of
remove that bias and I've seen a few
papers that claim to kind of work on it
including that word vector paper that
that Haytham mentioned I don't know of
any it's definitely not a solved problem
I'm sure and I think a lot of approaches
either just want to make you aware of it
or hopefully may be trying to remove
those data elements can it get to you
you know 80 percent of the way there but
I'm not sure if it really does
more than Carly
they usually give you
but do you have any
oh ho man the question was around
causality and isn't that what we're
really after yeah probably
if that's a that's a much bigger harder
topic then I think I would ever want to
buy done and I know there are some
approaches kind of approaching causality
or claim new approach causality through
data but I definitely don't have an
answer for that question Chuck
entrusting your own
yeah yeah yeah the question was do we
use any approaches in a our company to
avoid over trusting any particular model
and I think if I'm had an answer because
I can't think of one well I mean
definitely there's a lot of when
verifying our models we don't just kind
of ship them to production once we find
that there's good accuracy there's a lot
of what we do is like walking through
the models and showing a lot of example
cases from our production data and
looking at the recommendations and a lot
of times we'll throw them throw some of
those recommendations that we would that
we simulate to domain experts that walk
through that and verify does this
actually make sense because you could
get cases that I don't know like in
healthcare for example where you can
treat a disease by killing a patient so
definitely there's a lot of like
business logic and filtering through and
walking working with domain experts in
certain areas to make sure what your
models doing is valid sound follows
domain knowledge so let's thank you